i think there's a common misconception
and i had it originally i'm very guilty
of this i'm like oh esports
those aren't athletes right when people
say they're not athletes why are they
wrong
so i'm not going to start from the
furnace they are wrong right like i
think that whether or not someone is an
athlete or whether or not something is a
sport is an arbitrary line drawing
exercise
that reasonable humans can disagree
about right like
it you know whether or not league of
legends is a sport
is is on some level irrelevant right
like it's just about how many people
care about and
right does it become part of the
cultural zeitgeist right so do we
care if some third party decides on the
definition of sport and that we don't
fall into it does that matter or is this
really just about
how popular it is how many people want
to watch the thing
engage with the thing and call it a day
right there are tons of sport
like does anyone argue about whether
track is a sport
outside of the olympics every four years
does anyone give a [ __ ] about track
good point
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks folks this
is zach grauman
your co-host excited to be with you all
and really excited because today is
thursday and you know what that means
we're focused on the future of our
special limited series
and today's topic is the future of
esports competitive gaming folks
so i saw this youtube video of a guy
saying that more people watched the
league of legends world championship
than watched the college football
playoff and that was in 2016. and that
blew my mind i said i gotta get this guy
on the podcast
we did his name is bryce blum founder of
theorycraft and
uh he basically advises all of the
players in the esports world from
contract negotiations to
sponsorships on a corporate level he has
knowledge about the inner workings and
the high level picture of where this
industry of competitive gaming and
esports
is going it is mind-blowing holy crap
talk about a world
that doesn't get enough attention so i
asked him a whole bunch of questions
that what is this where is it going is
this really a sport does not matter and
he put me in my place a number of times
i learned a ton carly riley joins
uh who's a recurring co-host for us as
our finance director on the presidential
campaign always love carly's perspective
the the title this episode is is the
next
is the next lebron james a video gamer
which i'm being a little facetious but
the concept
is that is someone as iconic as lebron
james
is the next person who's gonna be that
iconic potentially
a video gamer and guys by the numbers
that is not as far-fetched as it sounds
so tune in
listen up the future of esports on yang
[Music]
speaks
all right folks welcome to your next
episode
of yang speaks the future of and we are
talking about the future
of sports specifically esports and i'm
i'm so freaking excited we have someone
who's
i think so unique at this point in
let's call it the existence and future
of a certain industry and that is
esports so bryce blum has joined us
today and bryce
is the founder of a firm called
theorycraft but what he does is advises
i'm gonna say anyone and everything on
esports
competitive electronic sports and gaming
and
this industry is blowing up essentially
already has blown up yet no one is
truly talking about it enough given the
scale it's got so
we've got bryce here and we're also
joined by the one and only carly riley
always love your perspective so both of
you
welcome thank you for being here i
always love being here me too i have
always loved being here
tell us like as a simple question what
is an esport what is esports how do you
define it i usually
say esports is the umbrella term that
refers to professional competitive video
gaming
um so you know video games already
esports what basketball is to the nba
right so as you can imagine there are
far more games and gamers than qualify
as esports much like there are far more
people who play
some form of sport than are doing it at
the you know point zero zero one percent
highest professional
you know level you know put a different
way esports are the very bottom of the
gaming funnel
it's not just like people playing madden
online right these are very
i mean some of them like invented worlds
right tell me how like
how's it work yeah there are esports you
know ecosystems built around the sport
simulation games fifa being the biggest
but madden and nba 2k have very large
competitive scenes as well
none of them are in the top five most
popular esports right the the biggest
esports in the world are games that you
may or may not have heard of right
league of legends the most popular
video game on the planet the most
popular esport on the planet
um is and has been you know for close to
a decade now
is kind of the marquee esport but then
you have other titles that you're
that you might be familiar with
counter-strike which has been around in
some
form for the last 20 years right as
we've gone through the different
iterations of the game
dota call of duty fortnite
overwatch right these are the these are
the big titles when you're thinking
about esports
why do you think that is like why do you
think those games
really capture people at the scale that
they do more so than like these sports
games or you know madden and fifa and
those
there are a bunch of reasons right
there's there's no one specific reason
why sport simulation esports are less
popular but a few of them are one sport
simulation games tend to be most popular
on console
pc gaming right is playing on your
computer at home
console gaming is xbox playstation and
there are
more people who have played a game of
league of legends on planet earth then
currently own
an xbox or playstation so the
addressable market for a console game is
smaller than it is for pc game and these
games historically have all been played
on console
there's also elements of this that are
first the
core sport simulation games are 1v1
games at least historically there's some
innovation happening around that right
now but
um historically you played madden you
know me against you and that means that
a
whole bunch of what is happening in the
game is ai right you're not controlling
it you're the
quarterback who throws the ball but
whether or not the receiver
catches the ball whether or not a
defender intercepts it
generally speaking he's outside of the
control of the player and so it's a
little bit less compelling in that way
um and then i also just think you know
there are
there is a subset of people who play
sports based video games and they tend
to be
fans of the sport themselves and so it's
just a smaller market than if you're
looking at
all of the people who play game i mean
you know there are 3 billion gamers in
the world
right and so billion yeah and so when
you find
the you know the best of the best
competitive game you're not gonna have
three billion people playing league of
legends but you
you know it's peak it's over a hundred
million monthly active users for league
of legends right and so
there's just so many more potential
players of those games out there than
there are for the sport simulation games
where you're really mostly interested in
if you're also interested in the sport
itself
carly did you grow up playing video
games no
uh and it's actually this is a question
that i'm sure gamers will hate me for
and i know it like people
like to push back on it so i want to
hear the pushback i wasn't allowed to
play a lot of these games because my
parents were opposed to the violence
and the violence in the games and my mom
was was very worried about it
making people more violent or aggressive
or angry do you
do you hear that bryce and what's your
what do you sort of say to that
yeah i hear it all the time i hear it so
often that about a year ago
in in i can't remember where there was a
mass shooting um
and there was some connection that the
person played call of duty and
it wasn't in the us i think was in
germany or something and politicians
were
um talking about oh this is a gaming
related thing and so i was like i'm just
gonna dispel this myth so i
i compiled all the everything i'd read
over the course of my life about this
uh and spoiler alert there is absolutely
nothing that connects mass shootings or
violence to video gaming
there are far more and better studies on
the side that there is absolutely no
causal link whatsoever
than there are on a limited basis there
is some there is some proof that certain
types of video games have led to
increased aggression for example
right um but i for what it's worth carly
i grew up in the same household i wasn't
allowed to play games growing up my mom
thought that they it wasn't it was less
about violence and more that they rotted
my brain
and turns out that neither of these
things are true actually right there's a
ton of good research out there
not every video game right if you're
playing you know 10 straight hours of
grand theft auto that's probably not the
most enriching thing
but the esports the esports games we're
talking about right league of legends
and counter-strike these are
deeply complicated and cerebral games
that require an enormous amount of
of team cohesion teamwork overcoming of
adversity creative problem solving
etc and so there's actually a lot a
growing body of research that these
types of games are
incredibly enriching they that they
improve performance
uh you know not just in in stem related
but across the board in school
um so there's a lot of and there's a
great um
there's a great uh ted talk on this that
jane mcgonicle did about
gamers saving the world that's that's
worth watching um
but yeah i mean i i grew up in that same
household and turns out that my mom
you know lied to me or i guess the more
charitable interpretation is she wasn't
reading the research right
so yeah
when i was in college i used to take
this super food
green smoothie i used to buy one every
day and they were great
and then i moved to manhattan can't
afford them it's like 50 times the price
so how i've substituted that out is with
athletic greens and i've been talking
about them for a while and they're
awesome it's just powder you put it in
water put it wherever you want and you
get
with one scoop minerals and whole food
source ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood
blend and more and they all essentially
work together
to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet increase your energy and focus and
aid with digestion and support a healthy
immune system which is important
during covid and you don't have to take
lots of other supplements so right now
athletic
greens is doubling down on supporting
your immune system and they're offering
our audience a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase so if you visit our link today
you'll basically never have to buy
vitamin d again
so visit athleticgreens.com yang and
join health experts athletes and health
conscious go-getters around the world
who make a daily commitment to health
every single day again
athleticgreens.com get your free supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
[Music]
league of legends seems to be a
different beast so what is that
let's i know nothing besides some of the
quick research ideas let's assume i know
nothing
how does it work you wouldn't believe
how many times i've gotten this question
and i'm still
pretty bad at answering it it's so
complicated
yeah i mean leo legends it's kind of
like if someone asks you to explain
football
right like where do you start right like
okay so there's you know a bunch of
people on the field you alternate
between offense and defense
you can throw the ball you can also hand
it to people
there's there's a there's a line of
scrimmage which is like a line
where no one can cross it until the ball
is hiked oh and hiking the ball is when
the center oh a sinner is a guy on the
line oh wait what is the offensive line
right like
it's actually amazing and we haven't
even gotten to anything right i haven't
explained anything about what football
is
it's kind of the same thing i mean
league of legends is played five on
five there are elements of the game that
are very individual you
start in what are called lanes for most
of the players so
there is there are two there are three
lanes two lanes where people
participate individually one where it's
a pair and then there's a kind of a
neutral area in the middle of a map
called the jungle and so everyone has a
jungler that kind of
roams around the map and makes play
throughout the game starts off in a more
kind of
siloed way and as the game progresses
you you move more towards like playing
as a five man unit and kind of five man
against five man but there are also
strategies that involve kind of
separating the map and you know one team
really wants a five-man fight and the
other team is like we don't want to give
you that we'll
put one person top one person bought and
we'll just constantly disengage and put
pressure on the map
elsewhere the ultimate goal of a game of
league of legends is to destroy
the other side's base their nexus and in
order to do that you need to
kill towers along the way that are
protecting that base but
how you get there and what a game of
league of legends looks like varies
wildly the
important thing i think for our purposes
is it's a 5v5 game
um where it requires an incredible
amount of strategy based on the
characters that you pick
uh and how the game flow works and
playing from behind is very different
from playing from ahead playing
from ahead with this set of champions is
different than playing with that set of
champions but it's
every bit as complex as what's happening
on the field of football just
in the same way that a football fan can
watch and appreciate the nuances between
zone and man-to-man defense and be like
oh my god aaron rodgers just looked off
the safety in order to create the space
for
the out route or whatever right a league
of legends fan is doing the same thing
when they're watching it it's just
if you don't know the game you don't
know the game when you get to um
the higher stakes tournaments you play
series usually best of fives and
i i always analogize it to like a tennis
match where each game is a set of tennis
and you're trying to be the first to you
know get the three sets
so i was having this conversation a
couple months ago with some friends
about
why we haven't had any new sports
invented right ignorant of esports right
we're like there hasn't been
a lot of these sports football hockey
soccer baseball
basketball they've been around for
hundreds of years right and human beings
evolve different ways like we were
creative enough to create new sports
and we were talking about the barriers
to entry
for those sports these traditional
sports are pretty
high right where you usually in order to
become a competitive let's call it
become an nba player become the pinnacle
of your game
you need a ton of parental support you
need to start at an early age
you need to find other kids who have the
same parental support and start early
age
and basically when you're young you are
learning the same
100 year old 200 year old rules of how
the game is played and there's some
beauty to that
for sure but that also prevents
some of the best athletes in the world
from playing newer games right they're
mastering some of these old games in a
different way
and with esports let's call league of
legends like you if someone creates a
new game they probably have
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
new video games coming out and if people
people can find it online if it's good
other people join it and if it's really
good other people start really mastering
the craft and the barrier to
create a completely new sport has now
been essentially eliminated or
vastly lowered um would you agree with
that is that one of the reasons why some
like this thing is so complex
way more complex in football some of the
like hand-eye coordination
is extraordinarily elite i know you
showed me a video of someone
like firing off with a controller like
rapid speed incredible hand-eye
coordination in order to do you know
execute at these levels like agree with
that statement i don't know your
thoughts on like how this is
kind of morphed into something new yeah
i sort of agree sort of disagree so
first of all there are
definitely newer sports i mean no one
was playing frisbee golf
20 years ago right you know there are
certain sports like
cross country that have been around for
thousands of years right and then other
sports that have been around for
hundreds of years or a hundred years
right uh it's not like the nba
is 300 years old right um but point
taken right like the the arc of
traditional stick and ball sports tends
to be a much kind of longer story than a
typical video game
and that's absolutely the case i mean if
you look at the history of video games
it's it's one where we're constantly
pushing the bounds of what's possible
from a technological perspective
and so there's a lot of innovation
happening and a lot of
therefore new and better games that are
coming out but
this the esports overlay to this is
really interesting because
if you know i mentioned the most popular
esports being league of legends and
counter-strike well league of legends is
a decade old and still the most popular
game there have been
hundreds of games thousands of games you
know millions of games that have come
out in this decade
right some of them have become
incredibly popular right like
you've probably all heard of ninja and
fortnite right or if you haven't a lot
of your audience has
you know will leave legends still be the
most popular esport in 30 years
i don't know but it's possible right and
that's
riot games bet by the way riot games bet
is that they're creating a generational
esport and riot games is the developer
of
league of legends exactly and their
their hope is that in
30 years when we're listing the biggest
sports in the world we're going to say
soccer and we're going to say league of
legends
right and i don't know if ryde is going
to win right the
odds are against them it's really hard
to stay that popular for that long
but i am 100 sure that whatever the most
popular esport is in 2050
it will be that popular that we will be
saying a video game and soccer
because the the global market
penetration of
gaming is already to that extent and
when you compare that to
the other big stick and ball sports you
know basketball football baseball
whatever
they are phenomenon that exist in some
sub-section of the globe right depending
on the sport
you know there's a different answer
baseball is very popular in the u.s also
in south america and certain parts of
asia
football is mostly just popular in the
us but certain parts of europe
basketball is very popular in certain
areas of asia very popular in europe
very popular in some other regions right
but
the kind of the global potential of
being the most popular
competitive video game is just higher
than it is for basically any sport
that's not soccer
is accessibility a part of why it's so
big though and i think
more so than what you're saying zach
what strikes me is like there's like
physical limitations to becoming a pro
athlete like i could never be a
professional basketball player
just by virtue of my like stature you
know like it was just never happening
for me
but that's not true there's actually
it's like more accessible
in some ways these gaming sites these
games are or at least i would think of
them that way
is that a factor in this the ceiling for
being the you know the upper echelon of
a top-tier esport is every bit the
ceiling that exists for traditional
sports right to
zach's like pipeline that pipeline
question the pipeline doesn't really
exist yet because
we haven't had a generation of you know
we even have the second generation of
esports fans
it's starting to happen right like i'm
having my first kid in may and
thank you thank you i'm very excited uh
and i will i will watch
seahawks games with her but i will also
watch team liquid versus cloud9
right and and that'll just be part of
our life and she will grow up in a world
in which
she is indoctrinated not just into her
dad's sports fandom but into her esports
phantom
right and when you think about how we
get our sports fandom by the way
it's exactly where you would think we
would come from over 98 sports fandom
comes from one of two places you get it
generationally from your parents or you
get it from your geography right and we
haven't created those dynamics and
esports yet but we will
and to return to your core your core
question carly
right this pipeline is going to exist
and in order to be a top
esports you know player athlete whatever
term you want to use
it's every bit as hard as it will be to
get into the nba and it's not
side strength speed agility that's going
to be the separating criteria
but it's going to be mechanical skill
right and
under in your ability to control your
you know whatever your controller your
mouse your keyboard
as well as an enormous amount of
real-time
complex strategic decision-making you
know when you're talking about a
group of league of legends players you
know it's we we commend aaron rodgers
for his
football iq or tom brady right and there
are tons of players in all the different
sports lebron james
is another one we talk about all the
time where it's like his basketball
queue is off the charts
you don't need an off the charts
basketball iq to play in the nba though
you can just be a very good basketball
player
you need an off the charts you know game
iq for all of these games you cannot be
an elite level counter-strike player or
fortnite player or rocket league player
or league of legends player
without an off-the-charts iq for the
game and so
we're testing for different things but
we're very much sorting for the
zero one .0001 of capability of humanity
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by parachute and i cannot
shut up about parachute like wouldn't
shut up about it so much that my
sister-in-law
just got uh she's moving in a new house
and she just bought a bunch of things on
parachutes website um
and they're awesome i have their sheets
i have their towels i don't know how to
explain it's like
lying it's like sleeping on a freaking
cloud
it's so fluffy and lovely i get out of
the shower i wrap myself in like the
bathrobe situation
yeah it's amazing guys seriously
parachute is unbelievable they believe
in making
home your happy place and trust me when
i say this
it actually does make it a bit of a
happy place it is worth every penny
so visit parachutehome.com com
slash yang for free shipping and returns
on parachutes very comfortable premium
quality
home essentials you will not regret it
it's amazing
the quality cannot be beat you'll feel i
don't know you'll just feel like you're
wrapped in joy all the time
it's pretty awesome parachute home dot
com slash yang
[Music]
so how we fou how we found how i found
you bryce was talking i have a friend
that works in like the event a lot of
parts of esports and he
uh sent me this video of you the point i
remember vividly
and this was in 2016 we made this video
where you showed a bar graph
and the number of people watched the
ncaa college football playoff
championship
and i think that was like 20 some odd
million and then you showed the number
of people who watched the league of
legends
championship and it dwarfed it doubled
it was in 40 million plus or so
so and that was five years ago um
talk to me how big we're talking here
yeah i think it's a great question and
it's a good uh it's a good moment for me
to do a little bit of a mea culpa
and and be realistic about some mistakes
i made earlier on my career where
um putting that i you had that reaction
for a reason right i wanted you to have
that reaction right i wanted you to
think
wow are esports bigger than traditional
sports but there's a reality to
the way in which esports viewership is
measured particularly at that time
where it was measured in total and i
talked about this during the
presentation i believe right i talked
about you know
what i used to say is it's an apple
storage's comparison you're comparing
total uniques to nielsen ratings
what it actually is is an apples to lug
wrenches comparison
right you're comparing you're comparing
on nielsen ratings a weighted average of
people who are watching a broadcast at
any given point in time controlling for
number of
human beings that watch a tv on average
and
in total uniques you're comparing the
number of devices that have watched at
least
a second of a broadcast right and so
it's pretty it's pretty misleading and
it led to misleading headlines like the
league of legends world championships is
bigger than the nba finals that's a
headline that was run everywhere from
espn to cnbc because no one unpacked the
data
and i would unpack the data during my
presentation and i would make these
points but i
but i should never have used the graph
in the first place you guys are building
your brand though you're building your
sport
and it is so much bigger than i think
people realize which is fundamentally
the point
yeah absolutely but the nice thing is
right we've we've evolved
we've both grown a lot in the last five
years and we've evolved in how we're
showing the data so for example
the league of legends world
championships last year had over 100
million
unique viewers totally unique viewers
but they also measured what
what is a new digital measurement uh
statistic called average minute audience
and it's
not one to one with nielsen but it's
much closer
and in many ways average minute audience
is actually a better statistic because
it's more clear
what we're actually saying we're saying
at an average minute
of this world championship this is how
many people were watching
right and it's and it's valuable and in
last year there were 22 million people
in the ama of the league legends world
championship so
you know it wasn't that big five years
ago i don't actually have that number
from five years ago right but it was
probably in the ballpark of three to
five million ama
at the time in 2016. so we've grown a
tremendous amount and now we actually
are in a world where we can say hey
you know an ama of 22 million that
actually is bigger than for example
like the world series viewership right
so we actually are in a place where we
can do the direct comparison
and say on our own two feet the macro
point i always make when we talk about
viewership is
listen we're we're in like the top half
of the second inning of this thing
what was really interesting to me about
about that video was the
the visuals you showed showing like what
i think it was league of legends what
the league of legends like world final
championship
looked like i don't i think it was like
maybe 2011 or i don't remember exactly
the first
the first year and it's like you know
kind of scrawny and it's like
some like teenagers it looks like in
like a conference room
or whatever and then it shows what in
2016 that league of legends final looked
like and it's in
its stadium level like it's it's huge
that was the visual that really stuck
with me and
that speaks that those growth trends so
i think i think that's worth talking
about just
a how much it's grown sort of 2016 to
now but um
but sort of what you foresee in that
yeah so it it
so the setup is that it's you know every
if you were
there it would feel like traditional
sports in every way except for you would
have no idea what's happening on your
screen right
you're walking around saying you're
seeing you know a bunch of fans wearing
the merchandise the jerseys of the
famous you know their favorite team
their favorite player there's color and
play-by-play commentary they're kicking
to
an analyst desk in between games which
is the equivalent of you know a
half-time
show right you're you're going to the
nba on tnt desk or
you know what have you the equivalent
for every sport you're seeing sponsor
logo integrations on the screen and
there's giveaways or you know live event
activations it really is
traditional sports in every way and to
carly's point we've evolved a lot i mean
you know as good as that world
championship was in 2016
you know three years later the league of
legends world championship won a sports
emmy right i mean it's a
you know it's a the level of production
around this stuff you know i is is it's
mind-blowing right it's
it is every bit going to a tier 1a
sporting event you know i've been to
i've been to
nba finals games i've been to a super
bowl i've been to all this stuff really
the only thing that for me
from a production level is a tier above
is a super bowl which is
the marquee live sports event on planet
earth basically every year from a
production standpoint
but you know going to league of legends
world championships is like going to the
nba finals i mean you know
the last time it was in the us it was at
the staples center and zed
played the pre-show with a custom song
that he did
for the league of legends world
championships and they rose up
these clear screens all the way up in
the staples center
and they had 3d custom art visuals going
all the way around it and i got
goosebumps like it was
it was unbelievable visual spectacle in
terms of what they are creating so
um yeah i mean we have you know as the
audience has grown
the you know investment has grown the
production quality has grown
really all of this has improved
dramatically you know as big of a jump
as we made from 2011 to
2016 we're making a similar jump from
2016 to 2021.
i'm always fascinated by companies that
are built
you know let's with the digital world in
mind right but there's no brick and
mortar
so everyone everyone watching is
watching online like that is so
different
than the super bowl where most of the
people watching are watching on
not even cable tv broadcast tv right
they've got so
um totally different immersive
experience that frankly the monetization
options and sponsorship options and
interaction with the athletes
are are pro probably endless
[Music]
all right this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by the new yorker i don't
know if you guys watched the hbo
documentary on alan v
farrow it's fascinating but one of their
best journalists at the new yorker is
ronan farrow and
he's a genius the new yorker is
just one of the better places where you
can get real deep dives into specific
topics and stuff i i've always been
interested but haven't particularly
spent time on reading so i read two
articles i found fascinating i found one
about
uh american christianity and how it's
shaped frankly and gone to places that i
didn't think
christianity was going to and it's
really become very political in a weird
way
and then that was called the wasting of
an evangelical mind and the other one i
read was
was called emails making us miserable
which it is um so this type of stuff you
get
from the new yorker which is fascinating
so here's the deal for a limited time
you can get 12 weeks of the new yorker
for just six dollars that's a savings
you get 50
off it's awesome plus listeners of our
show will receive an exclusive tote bag
to carry around for free
so go to newyorker.com yang that's
n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r
dot com slash yang to get 12 weeks new
yorker for six bucks
and free tote bag newyorker.com
yang
[Music]
i want to talk about the athletes and
this structure we love watching our
athletes succeed and fail
on the field like if there's a human
element have celebrities started to pop
up like how does the athlete
dynamic work in esports yeah absolutely
i mean of course there are celebrities
right in the same way
that when you follow a traditional sport
you fall in love with
the best player the most interesting
player or some combination thereof
you're doing the same thing in esports
and depending on what game you follow
and what region you're watching
you're you know different people are
going to be a household name for you so
you know a nba fan you know would freak
out if lebron james walked by them on
the street and
you know someone doesn't follow the nba
at all might be like that's a
unusually large and physically fit human
being but like
maybe they don't know or lebron james is
probably a bad example here right
because he's
reached a level of kind of mainstream
penetration that everyone but like
you know uh what about someone who's
like a very famous basketball player but
who isn't quite at that level
right uh i don't know who's yeah josh
allen i'm a buffalo bills fan i see josh
down he's great sure he's amazing but
he's young he's not he's not
john james maybe and i will football
yeah depending on what game you follow
you absolutely have your celebrity
they're
you know the top of these of the
performance ladder
you know making seven-figure salaries
and have hundreds of thousands of
followers on social platforms and
you know they're a big deal that's
something yeah they get paid seven
figures like some of the like what's the
average and then what's the top end of
what people are getting paid to do this
some of these numbers have been released
for league of legends specifically so i
can talk about them i do a lot of these
deals
yeah so i can't i cannot comment on any
of those but i can tell you that
the the north american league of legends
league which is the the
um you know the biggest north american
league for the biggest esport in the
world right now releases these figures
and the average salary is
somewhere around 350 000 and on the high
end they're in the seven figures
it seems to me that there's actually
even a higher level of intimacy between
the players
and their fans in the esports world
because you have things like twitch
where some of these players have come up
live streaming and talking directly to
the fans
and so there's actually even more of a
connection between the players and the
athletes than you see in traditional
sports is that
right yes absolutely 100 right and it's
an area where traditional sports are
over time going to model after esports
instead of the other way around because
we are quite frankly better at this than
stick and ball sports are so sure you
know
to put to put in perspective right twi i
want to unpack twitch carly because i
think very few people know what twitch
is
that are outside of this world twitch is
where we consume
a lot of our content youtube is the
other big place right
both live streaming you know live
streaming twitch and youtube vod mostly
just on youtube
and what you're doing when you're
watching that right let's just break it
down in a way people understand
lebron james goes to play pick up
basketball he slaps a gopro
onto his chest while he's playing pickup
basketball with a bunch of other nba
players and so
you're getting a behind-the-scenes
glimpse at what he's like in a more
casual setting how he interacts with him
he's talking [ __ ]
he's you know having a good time
bantering back and forth he's also
working on his game though he's
you know practicing his lefty hook shot
today and so he's
you know he's talking through everything
from how he gets in the block how he
creates space for the shot what he's
doing with his footwork how he's
thinking about how the defense is
approaching it
you know what he does if he gets double
teamed all these things
and then where this analogy really
breaks down is with twitch chat you know
he's also got a
live feed of everyone watching him that
are memeing with him and asking him
questions and commenting on things and
he's responding
to them in real time right and so
that is happening every second of every
day on twitch if you if you have
if you're completely uninitiated if you
no idea what we're talking about
right now go to twitch.tv and click on a
random stream and see what i'm talking
about and understand that
there are you know to put twitch in
perspective right is the second most
popular live streaming platform
behind only uh netflix in the us
twitch's popularity is
wild right i mean they're doing over 10
billion hours watched annually
the average twitch user goes back to the
site for over
two hours per session and they have 16
million
daily users on twitch right so it is
this is a hub not just of gaming
culture but of some other subcultures as
well but gaming is the is the primary
focal point of twitch
um and it's it is wild what we've been
able to do and breaking down some of
these barriers between
the celebrity and the fan it strikes me
as like part of this broader trend that
we see in
content and like the future of content
right like when i grew up i watched like
disney channel and it was highly
produced and it was on tv and it was
like very
you know managed and it feels like where
content is moving for gen z
is much more like on youtube somebody
vlogging like it's
there's a raw quality to it where they
want to feel more like they're connected
to the person
as opposed to something that's like
highly produced and it feels like twitch
and and gaming is really like
a part of that trend yeah absolutely the
democratization of content is everything
i mean look at what we're able to do
right now right i mean you know it's
relatively straightforward the
technology we're using basically
everyone has in their home right or the
overwhelming percentage of you know
americans at least
and have in their home and available to
them and it's funny to see some of these
things went out right just to derive
from your your kind of what how people
think through
broadcast quality um and you know level
production
riot games produced their version of
sportscenter right and poured
millions of dollars and had access to
every guest under the sun to create like
the marquee league of legends talk show
and a couple of influencers who
literally just did this they sat at home
and they
recorded themselves and they brought on
guests and they just talked about things
zero production quality
blew them away from viewership because
it was it was less polished it was what
we wanted to see it was raw it was
real they were calling it like it is if
a team was you know
doing terribly they were like this team
sucks and here's why they suck whereas
when you're producing sports center you
don't do that you kind of have to like
you know oh they're gonna take something
yeah right and it's like we don't want
that like we want to just have a
real conversation about what this is um
and so it's it's yeah twitch is
absolutely part of this general movement
of the democratization of content
it's really cool i'm thinking right now
if i could
listen to josh allen during his
practices
talking about what he's thinking how
he's throwing a football if you're a tom
brady fan or like you if you're
if you're a leonard tom hanks fan
leonardo dicaprio and he's talking about
how he's approaching a scene and doing
it seamlessly and casually
and reacting to freaking comments as
he's doing it
i would pay money for this like i and um
uh
and i imagine people do well i think
that's the other piece of this is the
monetization
element of twitch that's different than
traditional sports because
you can you can pay right on twitch
right so if i'm gaming somebody could
could kind of pay me directly as they're
watching me and that's where this also
feels like there's
there's all sorts of upside in the world
of esports like almost like salaries
that don't exist in traditional sports
or or are there rules around
professional gamers getting money on
twitch
no no they can yeah go and go and do
your thing right there
there are some differences in how
traditional sports for c sports are
monetized on the sponsorship level where
for the most part esports teams are
inventory aggregators so
you know it's very common for team x to
be sponsored by nike and player y to be
sponsored by adidas and traditional
sports
that's less common in esports part of
the kind of
package of what you're buying or some of
those rights of publicity and so
the team and players are collectively
promoting a group of sponsors
generically speaking but
stuff like twitch is really separate and
people monetize that independently and
yeah they monetize
they get donations on on twitch they
have people subscribe
for perks on the platform and for ad
free experiences
right you can run ads on twitch and the
broadcaster collects a cpm on that so
the content is free you can you don't
need to be a you know it's not like
netflix you don't need to be a netflix
subscriber it's not all behind a paywall
you can just go on twitch.tv right now
and watch this stuff
but you might get served an ad and you
might you know have
an opportunity to do other things to
support the creator if you so choose
sports at least historically and i still
think now
is so tied to culture um
and it's not just the united states
although that's a big one football
dominates here there's a cultural
zeitgeist that happens around our sport
and it hasn't happened with esports yet
and i feel like that's
to me where you real that's where you
get into mainstream
in my opinion so i want to start with
like the athlete piece
because i think there's a common
misconception
and i had it originally i'm very guilty
of this i'm like oh esports
those aren't athletes right when people
say they're not athletes why are they
wrong
so i'm not going to start from the
furnace they are wrong right like i
think that whether or not someone is an
athlete or whether or not something is a
sport
is an arbitrary line drawing exercise
that
reasonable humans can disagree about
right like it
you know whether or not league of
legends is a sport
is is on some level irrelevant right
like it's it's just about how many
people care about and you're right does
it become part of the cultural zeitgeist
right so
for example i'm a dire sports fan i have
been for my entire life right
yeah i would i watch you know i'm
college basketball
football right like these are these are
parts of my
everyday being right and have been since
i was born basically
but i would rather watch a dozen
different
esports than watch baseball much to my
dad chagrin right like he tried he tried
so
hard to make me a baseball fan outside
of the playoffs it is just
boring like i don't know how to describe
it like it is not compelling content to
me
and it might be compelling content
someone else and the reason why we have
these debates and there are people in my
industry who get
very up in arms about this debate by the
way are esports sports are the players
athletes
for me it's just like you're letting
people get under your skin for the wrong
reasons right like
do we care if some third party decides
on the definition of sport and that we
don't fall into it does that matter or
is this really just about
how popular it is how many people want
to watch the thing
engage with the thing and call it a day
right there are tons of sport
like does anyone argue about whether
track is a sport
outside of the olympics every four years
does anyone give a [ __ ] about track
good point i used to have so much fun
getting under people skin in the inverse
where they would i would say okay
you know esports sport what are sports
um and they would tell me oh you need to
be
a certain level of athleticism to play
and they give me the definition and i'd
be like
great by that definition baseball's not
a sport and i and uh
they'd say what are you talking about of
course baseball's a sport it's been a
sport forever and i'd say
well wait a second you told me that in
order for it to be a sport everyone who
plays
has to be an elite athlete i had an old
boss i used to fight with that said if
you can eat nachos while you play it
it's not a sport which would make
baseball if you're a right fielder
generally not a sport
totally and so it's it is very fun to
kind of play around with people
on this but it's only because of like
norms that if you tell them it's not a
sport it's less than right that's all
that's really happening
right if they would just reject the
premise of the discussion and say it
doesn't really matter to me if you
if you think baseball's a sport i like
it and i like watching it
we're fine right like you know i watched
a bunch of poker content in my life
right and
and it was and and it's people argued
for years about whether or not poker is
a sport i don't care
it's entertaining i watched a
documentary last night about speed
cubing
it is literally people who compete in
rubik's cube competitions
and there are audiences for this you
know with the big company they were
showing the world championships and
there's an auditorium filled with people
watching people solve rubik's cubes
as quickly as possible and it was
fascinating and am i going to go to the
the you know rubik's cube world
championship no i probably won't but
there are people who want to yeah
exactly right and so
you know chess is becoming really
popular on twitch is it a sport
no is it a video game no but like it's
entertaining so why do we care so anyway
so that's that conversation but i do
actually want to get back to the
core point you're making which is what
goes into being a you know an
elite player of these games and it is it
is harder
to visually grasp in the same way that
when you watch
you know a elite athlete do their thing
you know and you see
you know otto beckham jr jump four feet
in the air and catch a ball
with one hand extended all the way out
it's like holy god
the fact that a human being can do that
is wild it's wild right
and it's the same thing is happening in
in everything from counter-strike to
league of legends to dota to rocket
league
it's just happening in a form that's a
little bit harder to grasp because it's
mechanical skill
that is being expressed through a mouse
keyboard or console
it is a thought process the series of
decisions that are getting
that are getting made there is one of
the most famous league of legends plays
of all time is from the most famous
league of legends player of all time his
name is faker
he's a korean mid laner and it was a it
was a
mirror match so they were both on the
exact same champion which doesn't happen
very often for reasons that are not
relevant to this discussion
and he so thoroughly outplayed another
elite professional player on the same
champion
in the same moment that it was mind
numbing you have to
you have to watch it on slow motion 20
times to actually
understand just how thoroughly he owned
this person i mean it's the equivalent
of a basketball player
in a in the nba finals dribbling through
someone's legs
five times in a row and then dunking it
on on top of them right
and so these moments are happening the
skill is being expressed and
these people absolutely are in the point
zero zero zero zero zero one percent
right at the at the highest levels it's
just not quite as easy to tell with
someone
jumping really high or running really
[Music]
fast
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by better help
i am doing better help i'm actually
doing it once a week
it's like 90 bucks a week not even
for basically as many sessions as you
want to schedule and i talked to my
person let's call her sarah that's not
her real name but i won't i won't share
your real name but i talk to sarah all
the time i once a week and it's great
and we talk about a whole host of things
and you can do it too so you talk about
depression
anxiety stress relationships sleeping
trauma family conflicts anger you name
it we kind of cover the gamut
so i really do encourage this
particularly in covid guys like get this
stuff out of your
system it is awesome so here's our call
to action for you
i want you to start living a happier
life today and do what i'm doing
and as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month
by visiting our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over one million people and
me too
who have taken charge their mental
health that's betterhelp.help.com
yang
[Music]
one thing that i find really interesting
and find
to be part of the compelling case that
esports will be the future is a lot of
traditional sports team owners have
bought
esports teams right um so maybe
like i would love to hear from you a
little bit about that and just why you
really see esports as being the future
and moving into the mainstream or what
the case is for that yeah i've worked on
like dozens of those deals right so i
i've been in the room with the
sports team owner time and time again as
they're expressing why it's interesting
to them
and they're depending on who you're
talking about there are a bunch of
reasons why you know
cross promotion engage younger audiences
whatever but
across the board if there's one thing
that i think is at least in the back of
everyone's mind it's that
at some point someone paid 100 million
dollars for an mba franchise and
everyone thought that person was crazy
fast forward to today and the worst nba
franchise is worth a billion dollars
so there's a little bit of schmuck
insurance here of like the writing is on
the wall this is gonna be popular and
like
i have an opportunity on the ground
floor so why don't i just like plant a
flag there and see where this goes right
and where this is going 100
that is inarguable is full mainstream
penetration so
you know you've both made the point that
we're not there yet we're not there yet
in the us
we are there in certain places so so
korea south korea is kind of the mecca
of esports is where a lot of this was
born
and it's full cultural penetration in
south korea right i mean you know you
talked about
football being like that zach in the u.s
you know the the quarterback of the
football team in the small town in texas
is like guaranteed to be the most
popular kid at the school well
like the best league of legends players
like guarantee the most popular kid at
the korean high school right and
where are they going to hang out they're
going to hang out in pc bungs which are
basically
cafe bars where you can hang out drink
you know have fun with your friends and
play games and it's just a huge part of
korean culture
and there are places you know china is
another one where the mainstream
penetration is far ahead there
than it is here you know the most
popular league of legends player in
china
is sponsored by nike already right um
so there are places where that's already
happened now it has not happened for the
most part
in the us and we are trending very much
up right so ninja is the most famous
gamer most famous western gamer on
planet earth
he's a former halo professional player
former esports player or athlete
depending on what term you want to use
who became very popular along with the
game fortnite and he's
you know he's been on the cover of espn
the magazine and he
was part of a new year's eve times
square thing and
he has his own line with adidas and
he is insanely famous right i mean i you
know
uh he's a very well-known person
particularly among younger generations
now he
straddles the gaming esports line right
he's not an active esports professional
player anymore he's a former pro
turned full-time content creator
right but the ceiling of how famous a
gamer can be is already pretty high and
it's just going to keep going up right i
talked about as being in the bottom half
of the second inning this thing
you know pick an arbitrage what everyone
40 years old or younger
grew up in a world where video games
even existed basically right so that
means like
well over half the world population grew
up without them and we convert these
people all the time you know there are
people older than 40 who didn't grow up
with games who start playing games later
or become esports fans
but it's hard but the thing is in the
long run i don't need to convert them
right
uh i i frequently make a joke that
pisses people off which is every day a
baseball fan dies and two esports fans
are born
right um median media age of baseball
fans in the 50s
right the overwhelming majority of my
audience is under 35.
so every day more esports fans are born
and that's why i'm 100 convinced that in
30 years when we're listing the biggest
sports in the world
we're going to say soccer we're going to
say a video game because we're already
on this trajectory the writing is on the
wall i was on the wall then i said the
exact same thing
in a partner meeting at the third
largest law firm in seattle when i
started my career i started building a
practice that all the
you know old white dudes at my firm were
like what the hell is going on
and i said this is what's going on like
this is the data it's going to happen
it's inevitable and it was there were
also there were people there who
supported me but a lot of people who
didn't
right i went out and kind of forged my
my own entrepreneurial path for a reason
you know i said it in a talk in 2016 and
i'll keep saying it like this is where
this is all going it's going up and to
the right
in 30 years the most famous esports
players in the us
will be you know famous in the same way
that an nba player is famous this is
just inevitable
so if he says that people want to watch
other people play video games
open shot done i'm curious i think video
games andrew
this wrote about this in his book is um
something a lot of
men are attracted to um
but i also have this vision of
one of the first sports where men and
women can compete against each other
on without without the limitations of a
physical
um physical traits and like on
relatively equal ground i guess
the definition of equal ground is that
are you guys seeing
gender diversity and more women joining
the sport or i'm curious demographics
and
who's playing so by and large we're not
and it's a huge problem but to
to start with the premise you know it's
not correct to say that that
gamers are mostly or are like you know
predominantly men right of the three
billion gamers in the world somewhere
between 40 and 45 percent of them are
women depending on what market research
study you're looking at now
that is all gaming right there are
certain sections of the population
that are deeply interested in certain
types of gaming like if you want to know
the player base of candy crush it is
overwhelmingly women right and
there are millions of people that play
candy crush right so
uh the esports titles the league of
legends and counter-strike of the world
still
are predominantly men and there are
the layers of this problem we could do
an hour on gender discrimination in
gaming and it's something i try to
actively work on every
every chance i get and so here's what it
looks like right like why are there
fewer
female engineers than there are male
engineers right
it starts from a very young age when
parents tell their
you know daughters and sons what they
are and are not supposed to do you know
son
don't play with this doll go play this
sport
you know girl stop playing this video
game start doing this other thing
instead right it's unbelievable how much
these cultural norms affect us and
affect what we're interested in from a
very young age
and these things play out over the
course of the entire over your entire
life you know a girl
that was is super into video games in
high school is going to be treated
differently right there
there are cultural norms that tell her
she's a nerd she's an outcast right
she's an outlier she's not doing what
she's supposed to be doing
and it's a real problem and then you get
into the games themselves and
the harassment is unbelievable i mean
any any game where
there are voice communications if you if
you have friends who are women who play
games ask them what their experience is
like
and they will have one of two answers i
don't use voice communications in
in the game because i'm just i just
can't i don't want to be harassed i'm
over it
or two i do it and i'm constantly have
my teammates
harassing me saying horrible things to
me intentionally losing games because
the game because they're on the same
team as a girl it's uh it's it is
horrible um and so and then they face
harassment you know you you do get
through
all of this stuff to be a professional
female gamer in some capacity in a game
or a content creator whatever
and you are harassed constantly on your
social media handles on your twitch
stream
you know the the the parties in power
are
not doing enough job to correct this but
if we're being
honest about it this is a problem that
goes so
deep there are so many layers to why
these things happen and it's
you know there are there are a lot of
very good things that are happening you
know
girls who code write in projects like
this who are trying to push the bounds
of
getting more gender diversity in
professions where there is no reason why
they are dominated by men but there were
no one reason why but there are you know
all these layers of problem and it very
much exists in my industry as well i
hate it
i try to do what i can about it but yeah
you're zach the premise is correct
there is no reason why a man should be
better at league of legends
than a woman or a man to be better at
counter-strike than a woman but when you
look at the professional player base of
these games
they are almost exclusively men some of
them are 100 men there are
no women playing in the north american
league of legends championship series
and in
north you know and and that's a problem
new and innovative technologies
the cutting edge sadly a lot of times
when that is hap when they
in the nascent stages when they're being
built and the process is being built and
that's where they when it's
predominantly men the
the the issues you're highlighting
aren't addressed early on and so then
you have this entire system to fight
against to even rewire it once it gets
a little more popular i was a computer
science minor in college and i
you know i was sort of aware of of
this problem then because i had
professors who were into gaming or
into gaming platforms and would talk
about the harassment and i know in
conferences
it's always been really bad at gaming
conferences and and doxxing
is is a phenomenon that's very prominent
in the gaming community and
especially towards women so this was you
know probably seven years ago or
whatever that
this this was sort of at the forefront
of things i was thinking about and knew
about
but i haven't kept up with it like how
are you seeing improvements at least as
much as it still has a long way to go
at the margins we are seeing improvement
i mean i don't want to say that we've
seen no improvement because we have
there's some thoughtfulness around
this i mean you know riot games for
example it's not just the professional
player base it's throughout the gaming
industry right if you want to work in
gaming and you're a woman
the amount of adversity that you are
facing is significantly higher than for
your male peers
anyone who denies that as an idiot um
and there were you know for example
there were
active lawsuits against riot games and
there was a ton discussed about the
culture of riot games
and there were some things about acute
discrimination but there were also
things where like
they had a bar as part of their
admission process where it's like you
have to be a hardcore gamer otherwise
we're not really interested in hiring
you
and if you do that if you set a hardcore
gamer bar which on its face seems like a
neutral criteria we are a hardcore
gaming company
we want hardcore gamers working here you
are neglecting the reality that
a man is far more likely to be a
hardcore gamer because of all of the
other things i talked about leading up
to the moment in time
where this person applied to work at
riot games and so
um you know riot culture has changed
meaningfully it's not perfect there's
there was a lawsuit filed recently
against the ceo for gender
discrimination so
which is you know it's an allegation i'm
not saying it's true or false right i
have no idea but
it's not we're far from perfect on that
stuff but there have been
some improvements i'm always hesitant to
give us too much of a pat on the back
for this because
the the problem is still so bad and i
literally cannot have a conversation
with my female friends who work in the
industry without hearing more and more
stories about
what it is like to just be them and and
the the challenges that they face on a
daily basis the discrimination in a
business meeting you know
i'm i'm on the board of an amazing
company that is has two female founders
and
if i attend a meeting with them they are
the founders
they is their company i am just there
right
and we're across from a man in a meeting
one out of two times they'll have a
conversation with me like i'm like
you're asking about their company talk
to
them right like why is this a com i'm
here to support i can add some
context value whatever but like this is
a conversation between you and these two
amazing women and i'm along for this
ride
and it's just it is you know
as as much as we've come a long way over
the course of the last five years carly
we still have
so much more to go that's really
frustrating and
makes some sense this is sadly
not an exclusive problem to the esports
or the gaming industry and that
frankly we could have a whole podcast on
this um it's one of the reasons why
andrew and myself and carly have worked
in politics to try and solve some of
these on a society-wide scale
as we wrap this i want to talk
about what this looks like in the future
my vision was always like some sort of
blend of the physical and the digital
uh where do you think this is going
we're still a ways away from having
the like football played by human beings
without the physical contact where like
your size strength speed is expressed
through this virtual reality world and
you can have some of the upside of like
football and traditional sports in
general you express that without the
downside of you know literally killing
the participants right
um so you know maybe someday the
technology gets there i'm not a vr
expert so i can't say it's certainly
something that people are going to be
pushing
on and you know people will try and
whether or not vr
ever becomes the technology gets good
enough and it gets cheap enough to the
point where you have widespread adoption
which is
critical right because if you don't have
it then you can't get to that level
right
why is soccer the most popular sport in
the world it's not just because it was
played everywhere you have to ask why it
was played everywhere
and the answer is it's the lowest
barrier to entry sport you literally
just need a very cheap ball and you
don't you don't even need a goal or a
field you people play it on
street and you play all you you throw
down you know
any kids knows this you throw two two
jackets on the ground and it's a and
it's you know a goal right it's like so
easy so um
you know will vr ever get to that point
maybe right only time is going to tell
on that one and if it does then maybe
the most popular sport in the world will
be virtual reality or something
you know ar or something right uh part
of where this is going is mobile for
sure
right you know mobile games are the
fastest growing sector of gaming as a
whole
um and it is exploding in growth and
popularity
it's a complicated meshing of principles
though because
compelling mobile games are simple
enough to work on a small device
and they have a short enough session
time that it's like naturally suited to
the platform
and the best esports and sports in the
world tend to be more complicated and
tend to involve
longer session time there are some
popular mobile esports
absolutely you know pubg is a very
popular mobile esport for example
um you know clash royale very popular
mobile esport but
they're not on the same scale as
counter-strike or league of legends
someday that will get solved someday
someone is going to come up with the
right cross section of those two things
and you know i could easily see a world
in which the most popular esport is
mobile but we're not there yet
i think i've missed the boat a little
bit on this i i don't think i'll ever
become a gamer particularly
but i totally buy the premise that this
is the future and like this is where
things are going
so from like a business perspective i'm
like this is interesting
i want to learn more about it like where
do i go
what do i invest in what am i buying
uh from investment perspective it's
tough most of it's private and the
public exposure is
is um probably oversold and like you
know in practice there are like esports
etfs and things like that and
some of the people behind them are great
human beings and you know i think that
the goal there is really good but
if we're being honest about how much
esports exposure there is in the stocks
in the portfolio it's like really small
right like
you know the esports exposure even when
you're getting the biggest esports
companies you know blizzard activision
right which makes
overwatch and call of duty and uh riot
games is owned by tencent and tencent is
publicly traded on the chinese chalk
stock exchange and so you can
you know get tencent stock and you know
does amazon on twitch you buy amazon
yeah
amazon yeah exactly but like what
percentage of you know twitch is a giant
company but like what percentage of
twitch exposure are you getting when you
buy amazon stock right same thing as
like
what percentage of esports exposure are
you getting when you buy 10
cent stock well they own a steak and
supercell supercell sme sports they
don't stay can
riot riot has esports but like it's
mostly a games related investment not an
esports investment so
there are you know this trend is
changing there have been some esports
companies that have
that have gone public on the canadian
stock exchange i think one or two in the
us
there are lots of conversations around
spax and ipos for esports companies
so there will be more opportunity in the
public markets but right now most of
your investment opportunity on esports
is private for all of the reasons that
i've talked about this podcast esports
was a very sexy
investment topic and and still is to
this day uh and so you have a lot of
people who deployed capital into a lot
of ventures
of questionable success likelihood i
guess is a very generous way of putting
it
you know it's kind of like betting on
the internet right in the 90s
what i was going to say yeah for every
like google there's a hundred pets.coms
right where it's like i'm
to the moon with this internet thing
that you're hearing about and it's like
probably charitystar.com that's a great
idea
andrew yang actually solid idea
he started omaze before omaze but
amazing for amazing actually you know
his idea was actually good just got on
the dotcom bubble but
that doesn't stop my plan here i think
yankspeaks
should explore very seriously buying an
esports team
or something fun i'm dead serious about
this so if you're listening this you're
like yes and i have capital dm me
uh this will be amazing um bryce will
call you to handle all litigation and
strategy
um what we're doing what what are you
excited about 10 years from now
in this space uh 10 years from now
will be the period time where the
esports industry is going to start to
actually look like whatever it's going
to be when it grows up so
you know as with all things where you
have an enormous amount of investment
that pours in
and i alluded to this earlier i think
many of those things are going to fail
there's conversation around esports
bubble
you know i the analogy is fair in the
sense that there are esports companies
out there that are overvalued there are
companies that have raised millions of
dollars tens of millions of dollars that
are going to fail and fail big time
and that will cause some regression in
the market right some people who were
thinking oh my god this is so sexy
are gonna have a conversation with
someone who lost 10 million dollars on
their esports investment
and they're going to shy away but that's
okay with me because
quite frankly there's too much of some
of this stuff like too many players in
the field because it was like everyone
wanted to be in the esports space for a
time
and so for me 10 years from now will be
when we so have sorted all of that out a
little bit
the dust will have settled in the kind
of the post shake up and
evaluation normalization uh and we'll be
building the real
esports infrastructure of the future and
i'm excited because i don't you know i
have speculated about what that's going
to look like but i'm not positive
right like for example one of the big
aspects of the esports ecosystem even
talked about is the publisher
right like these are sports that are
owned you know no one has to pay the
naismith family a royalty to run and
broadcast a basketball tournament
you know as we've seen you can just run
one you know espn during the nba
offseason runs
the basketball tournament now what stop
what protects the nba's market share is
that they have all the best players
assigned to exclusive contracts and
if you want to watch the best basketball
that's where it's going to be and it's
really hard to imagine someone
disrupting it
you can try you know if you want to be
vince mcmahon you can create the xfl and
try to
you know run run up against the nfl you
can't do that in esports right the
publisher
has you know owns the sport and can stop
you from broadcasting it
and what that has led to is a series of
decisions that have caused the biggest
publishers to control
much if not in the entirety of their
esports ecosystem
i'm not convinced that's what this is
going to look like long term
it could it definitely could riot games
has for example developed as
assets blizzards or activision developed
an enormous amount of internal
capabilities around operating a sports
league
but at the end of the day their core
business is making games and making
those games good and creating compelling
monetization loops for them
not running a sports business and so you
know it would not
shock me if in the long run the majority
of esports were actually
run by third parties like the nba you
know hey
we have 30 indoor venues all over the
country we have deep connectivity to
everything you would need from media to
sponsorships to monetize the heck out of
this thing
um license it to us we'll pay you a flat
fee we'll give you some revenue upside
and like let us
be your sports league arm i i'm of the
belief there's a meaningful chance that
will be where this goes but
uh it time is gonna tell depending on
how the bubble bursts and
you know what are the implications of
that so i'm excited to be ten years down
the road and
see what we're actually building that
will be the infrastructure for the next
hundred years
that is exciting a lot of these leagues
exist and a lot of people know
a lot more about this to me but the
reason you know the nfl the nba exists a
lot of it's liability and also
profitability right it's like protection
it's easier to blame roger goodell than
xyz video game company right
um when goodell's protected by all the
owners and go down the list right
i'm grateful for your time bryce this
was fascinating
um where this goes will be mind-blowing
i always
i've always had a theory that if as soon
as an insurance company sponsors it then
it's officially mainstream um so when
geico
is calling to sponsor your uh your the
leagues then
we'll know and so hopefully 10 years
will come back and see if geico's
involved well
zach i i hate to interrupt you but i got
to do it i've done a guy called
sponsorship deal for and he's been no
way
so i guess we'll get him out
thank you sir thanks so much for for
teaching us yeah thank you for having me
keep kicking butt and we'll talk to you
soon yeah this was great thank you both
so much
[Music]
you